this week we're talking about migrating
streaming and generating insights with
your data on bigquery
I am Priyanka and welcome to this week
in cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news traditional data warehouses
can be expensive and difficult to
maintain as data rapidly increases in
volume velocity and variety we know that
businesses are turning to bigquery to
keep up so we've put together a quick
guide on how to start your migration
plan get prepared by creating a
migration plan and then going through
the full data warehouse migration guide
storing data in cloud storage helps you
not only keep your files accessible and
secure but also gets them ready for
real-time analysis by using cloud
functions you can run code every time of
file is uploaded and stream the data
into bigquery follow along and try it
out for yourself in the solution guide
now that you can move more data to
bigquery we're also making it easier to
work with your data using persistent
user-defined functions felipe has
another great post detailing out how to
create and share UDF's across your
organization check out the details to
create your own or use the ones that
Felipe shared
looking for some more guided practice
with bigquery will enroll in from data
to insights with GCP specialization on
Coursera you'll learn how to query and
process petabytes of data on big way
it's got interactive scenarios and
hands-on labs to give you meaningful
practice at skills that have never been
more relevant enroll today if you want
to read more about this announcement or
see a full list check out the link have
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you